- Please welcome Rosario Dawson and Retta.
(audience applauding)
Oh, I'm so happy to see you.
- It's so good to see you too.
- Hi.
- Rosario, I know you've moved East.
Kickin' it in Newark with your boyfriend.
- (laughs) Yeah, I'm a Jersey girl now.
I didn't see that coming.
- Welcome.
(all laughing)
- How do you like it?
- Thanks.
I'm learning a lot of different
Jersey factoids to be sure.
Jersey the home of saltwater taffy.
- Retta.
I'm so grateful because
you were kind enough
to do the pilot of this show.
And we put on blindfolds
and like had fun and did taste tests
and just had a really good time.
And it was such...
You honored this show
with your presence and
I owe you everything and
I want to work
alongside of you.
- You're welcome.
- For life.
And I just love you.
And I thank you.
And I'm so glad we're back
together here on this real show
and Rosario,
I have to tell you guys,
I am so blown away by your podcast.
It's amazing what you guys have done.
- This was kind of put together
by a bunch of different senators.
Women created a whole space, you know,
create a whole fund
and a whole committee for
this to make it happen.
So, you know, it was just about trying
to be as prepared as
possible for the Centennial.
- I think the production was amazing.
I really was like, "Dang,
am I part of that?"
Because I had no idea how
much was going into it.
- I think that, you know,
you listen to a lot of podcasts
and some of it's sort of
really fun and meandering.
Your guy's is incredibly focused.
It's so educational.
It's super interesting.
I was wrapped from the beginning.
It hooked me
and I was just so excited
to understand this history.
Why was it so important
for you guys to do this?
- For me,
one I was shocked
at how little I did know
about the suffrage movement
and anything that can encourage
more people to get registered
and get out to vote
and understand the importance of it.
You know voting has
a direct relationship
to what's gonna go on at your job,
in your supermarket,
in your towns, and your
restaurants, and all of that.
That made me say, "Okay,
"I don't like certain things.
"I might want to have a say in it."
- And Rosario, you talked
about your grandmother
being your influence.
- Yeah.
She was born and raised in Puerto Rico.
And as I say in the podcast, you know,
she raised me with the understanding
that just because she spoke
with an accent didn't mean
that she would think with one and
that she had a voice
even though she represented
a marginalized person
according to what she
represented on paper.
She was a mother of five single mother,
her daughter had me out
of wedlock as a teenager.
So we fell into the statistics
of people that so often are marginalized.
And what I loved about
this podcast in particular
was that it was starting
to show the history
of how women had been voting long before
the 19th amendment was ratified.
And that there were a
lot of women of color
who were still denied that
right even after it was.
And I think this podcast helps
to elaborate just how many more people
are part of a history that has made
it possible for us to have the rights
that we have today
and that we have to
stop marginalizing them
and discounting them from the story.
- And you said in the podcast
Rosario that you look to history
sometimes in the present.
And that's something I do too
because I want to
understand where we've been
in order to be more educated
about where we're going.
And I'm so honored to speak about it
on the show and you can go
to our website and get links to it.
And I just thank you guys so
much for coming on the show
and talking about it.
Hey, before you guys go,
can you do us a favor?
We wanted to try something
and you'll be the first people
to ever do it with us.
- Okay.
- Our VFFs our virtual friends and family
is called 15 seconds of Fame.
And they wanted to ask you a question
in 15 seconds that you would
have to answer in 15 seconds.
How do you feel about that?
(woman snaps fingers)
- [Retta] Alright.
- Okay, great.
Oh, hi, Brant.
(audience claps)
Brant, are you ready for your 15 seconds
of fame and your question?
- I am, Drew.
Thank you.
- Perfect.
Rosario, you're going to answer first
and then I'll go to you Retta.
And the clock starts now go.
- Rosario, what was first ever job
before you became an actress?
- I was a babysitter and a tutor.
Actually my very first job
was working on Sesame Street.
(audience cheers)
(bell dings)
- Retta, your turn.
- My first job was, I
was a cash cashier at a
Nickels which was like a Target (laughs).
- Perfect.
(bell dings)
(audience applauds)
- Okay I think that went okay.
I'm excited and that was really fun.
And I hope I get to get a
15-second answer because
I would not do well in 15 seconds
'cause I never know when to shut up.
So this was so fun.
(woman chuckles)
Thank you guys so much.
I really appreciate you guys coming on.
I love what you're doing
and we're here to shout
it from the rooftops.
Thank you so much.
Rosario and Retta's podcast is called
And Nothing Less and before we go to break
I want to show you a clip
from a documentary I worked on
years ago that we spoke about
that helped start my voting fire.
Alright, take a look.
Can I ask a question?
Are you going to vote this year?
Why do we have the lowest
rate of young voters?
- [Man] Give them a reason to vote.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- I have also come to believe
that we all passionately want
to feel a part of something
so that we are not alone.
And although though voting
is a very personal ritual
it brings us all together
in the most profound way.
(upbeat music)